welcome back to Downing Street for
today's Daily coronavirus briefing I'm
joined by Sir Patrick valance the
government's chief scientific adviser
and Professor John Newton who is
coordinating our work on testing the
government is working through our action
plan which has as its core that we must
protect life and protect the NHS both by
slowing the spread of the virus so that
we flatten the curve and by ensuring
that the NHS is always there to treat
all people who need its care according
to the most recent figures five hundred
and eighty three thousand four hundred
and ninety six tests for coronavirus
have now been carried out in the UK
including twenty three thousand five
hundred and sixty tests carried out
yesterday a hundred and thirty eight
thousand and seventy eight people have
tested positive for the virus that's an
increase of four thousand five hundred
and eighty three cases since yesterday
seventeen thousand six hundred and
fifteen people have sadly died seventeen
thousand six hundred and fifteen people
sorry are currently in hospital had
cracked myself with coronavirus down
from eighteen thousand one hundred and
eighty nine on the 21st of April and
sadly of those hospitalized eighteen
thousand seven hundred and thirty-eight
have now died and that is an increase of
616 fatalities since yesterday and
although this number is lower than it
has been in previous days I still stop
any think of each one they will not be
forgotten and their stories will live on
we must maintain our resolve and follow
the social distancing rules because they
are working they are protecting the NHS
and they're saving lives to lift the
measures too soon and to risk a second
peak would be a mistake it would undo
all of the hard work that's been done
and it would be both bad for our
nation's health and for our nation's
economy we could only start to change
the measures when the NHS can continue
to cope when the operational challenges
have been met when the daily death rate
falls sustainably and consistently when
the rate of infection is decreasing and
most importantly when there's no risk of
a second peak we need to bring the
incidence of new infection right down
we'll then use a rigorous program of
test track and trace and keep it down so
we can safely release more of the
restrictions and today I want to set out
the progress that we're making on test
track and trace which is such an
important part of the measures that
we're taking and the work that we're
doing first testing we set the goal of a
hundred thousand tests per day by the
end of this month I knew when we set it
that this was a challenging target
capacity is now ahead of our plans and
even overnight has increased from forty
thousand to fifty one thousand and
because capacity has increased so
substantially we're now able to expand
who can get the tests our ultimate goal
is that everyone who could benefit from
a test gets a test but of course we had
to start by prioritizing patients in
hospital followed by NHS and social care
colleagues and by those in care homes as
we expanded the capacity from just 2,000
tests a day at the start of March to ten
thousand tests a day at the start of
this month so we've been able to further
expand access today I can go further we
can make it easier faster and simpler
for any essential worker in England who
needs a test to get a test from today
employers of ascend
workers who will will be able to go on
goth you K to get a test for any of
their staff who need a test and from
tomorrow any essential workers who need
a test will be able to book an
appointment on golf K themselves
directly this all applies for people in
essential workers households too who
need a test it's all part of getting
Britain back on her feet those included
as essential workers will be based on
the list for schools and education set
out on gov
the whole process will be free and once
you've entered your details on the
website you'll get a text or an email
inviting you to book an appointment
after you've had your test results will
be sent out by text and a help desk will
be available to deal with queries people
who can't go online can still apply
through their employer I want to make it
as easy as possible for people to get a
test not least because we're talking
about people who are ill our network of
regional test sites has now reached over
30 locations right across the UK and
more being set up each day and I just
want to take this moment to applaud the
private companies who've been involved
as well as my team and team in public
health in England and the NHS boots
Amazon thermo Fisher ramdux Roche Oxford
nanopore GSK and Astra Zeneca they've
really stepped up to the mark and I'm
grateful to each and every one we're
also introducing home test kits and with
the support of the Armed Forces mobile
testing sites to the Armed Forces and
the mo D have played a vital role here
and I want to pay tribute to their work
I thought that yesterday's briefing
General Sir Nick Carter when he said
that coronavirus had presented the
single greatest logistical challenge in
his 40 years of service I thought that
spoke a truth our armed forces have
played their part in rising to this
challenge and I want to thank them all
in addition to testing essential workers
were also
using testing to find out how many
people have coronavirus and how many
people have had coronavirus these are
critical pieces of information to inform
our battle against this novel virus and
that we'll use to learn and we keep
learning about every day this week we've
begun one of the biggest virus infection
and antibody studies that this country
has ever seen this is a joint project
with the Office for National Statistics
bringing their experience of running
large household surveys and the
University of Oxford bringing their
world leading scientific expertise in
total twenty five thousand people will
take part in the first phase with plans
to expand it to up to three hundred
thousand people over the next 12 months
participants will provide regular
samples taken from self administered
swabs and answer a few short questions
during home visits by trained health
workers will use these tests to help us
strengthen our scientific understanding
and informers on the big choices that we
have to make about social distancing
measures and how we start returning to a
more normal life letters are arriving on
doorsteps from today please if you're
asked take part in this vital research
for your country the early signs from
today of it there is huge enthusiasm for
those who've received letters taking
part in this survey if you get a letter
please respond to it as soon as you can
because you will be doing your bit as we
ramped up our ability to test in large
numbers and as we slow the spread of the
virus we also need to make sure we've
got the ability to trace contacts just
as effectively as we look ahead this is
critical to keep the virus under control
and so we're putting the infrastructure
in place now so that we can roll out
contact tracing on a large scale we're
currently testing the new NHS contact
tracing app if you become unwell with
symptoms of corona virus you'll be able
to tell the NHS via this app the app
will then send an alert to other app
users that you've been in significant
contact with in recent days E
before you have the symptoms so that
they know and they can act accordingly
so we can get the test to people even if
they're asymptomatic if we're worried
that they have a significant they've
been in significant contact with someone
who has the disease we'll be able to let
them know but it's not just about the
technology we need the people too we
need to be really kick-starting contact
tracing as the new number of cases
begins to fall we're preparing for this
now by hiring an initial eighteen
thousand people including over 3,000
clinicians including public health
specialists we'll be training up the
mast ranks of our contact tracers over
the coming weeks and roll out the
service this test track and trace will
be vital to stop a second peak of the
virus but recent weeks have shown that
there is something we can all do and
that's to follow the rules on social
distancing I am acutely aware of how
difficult this has been and especially
as we enter Ramadan a month that is so
special for so many people this Ramadan
many Muslims who serve their country in
the NHS and in the Armed Forces and in
so many other ways will not be sharing
the joy of this month as they normally
do I want to say to all British Muslims
thank you for staying at home I know how
important the daily if there is how
important communal prayers are at night
and how important that each festival is
thank you for making major changes to
these vital parts of your practice and I
want to say to you all Ramadan Mubarak
and thank you for your service and
citizenship and thank you for your
sacrifice
this will help so that we can together
emerge from this challenge all the more
United all the more grateful to one
another and all the more safe we've
traveled together too far to go
backwards now so please stay at home
protect the NHS and save lives